dos días después de que el nuevo
presidente de eeuu joe biden
hiciera un llamamiento a la unidad el
congreso sigue dividido sobre si hacer
que el expresidente trump rinda cuentas
o no por el asalto al capitolio la
presidenta de la cámara nancy pelosi
insiste en que el juicio político debe
proceder
el hecho es que el presidente de eeuu
cometió un acto de incitación a la
insurrección
no creo que sea muy unificador decir
sólo olvidemos lo y sigamos adelante no
es así como se unifica a la semana
pasada a trump se convirtió en el primer
presidente de eeuu sometido a dos
impeachment tras que los miembros de la
cámara de representantes incluyendo a
diez republicanos votarán por presentar
cargos en su contra por incitación a la
insurrección la cámara alta se convierte
en tribunal para los juicios políticos
de los tres presidentes de eeuu que han
sido sometidos son en pitch meant andrew
johnson y bill clinton y donald trump en
2019 por abuso de poder ninguno ha sido
condenado a pesar de que los demócratas
tienen el control del senado
con kamala harris como voto decisivo o
un impeachment requiere una mayoría de
dos terceras partes a principios de
semana el entonces líder de la mayoría
republicana mitch mcconnell señaló que
estaba dispuesto a condenar a trump por
la turba fue alimentada con mentiras fue
provocada por el presidente y otras
personas poderosas el ataque al
capitolio que intentaba detener el voto
del congreso para confirmar la victoria
de biden dejó cinco muertos todavía no
se ha definido fecha para el impeachment
pero mcconnell sugirió la cámara baja
enviar el cargo contra el ex presidente
al senado el 28 de enero y dar así dos
semanas atrás para preparar el informe
previo al juicio retrasando
potencialmente el procedimiento hasta
mediados de febrero